well let's talk a little bit about
what's going on in the Republican
primary DeSantis got asked about uh the
hypothetical of if Trump ends up winning
the primary as right now he seems poised
to do would DeSantis endorse him support
him in the general election
um and as you can probably expect
DeSantis Dodge the question and start
talking about his handling of kovid and
Trump saying that New York handled it
better
um but we'll discuss this after taking a
look
regardless of a sexual you I'm 100 uh
pledge to support Trump as a GOP nominee
what I would say is this
um
when you are saying
that Cuomo did better on kovid than
Florida did
you are revealing yourself to just be
full of it nobody believes that and you
know why
[Applause]
and you know why I know that
because okay a couple of things then
we'll continue this is surface level
this is not super important but it
doesn't have an effect in politics
number one he always gets noticeably
nervous when he gets asked about Trump I
can kind of a little bit hear his breath
gets a little
um whatever you call that and also uh
people criticize him for this and I
didn't think about it that much until
now he really does have this really
whiny tone of voice but that's less
important continuing as I remember in
2020 and 2021 when he was praising
Florida for being open saying we did it
much better than New York and Michigan
and everyone was coming to Florida and
that we were one of the great governors
in the United States and he used to say
that all the time now all of a sudden
his tune is changing and I would just
tell people do you find it credible do
you honestly find it credible would you
have rather been in New York during
covid under Cuomo regime or would you
rather have been in the Free State of
Florida and I probably can count the
number of Republicans on my hand in the
nation who would have rather been under
Cuomo in New York and we know that and
so these are just uh frivolous
criticisms but uh in some respects I
think it shows that you know if you you
have to make that argument then you
probably don't have very good arguments
because the reality is everything he
said about us for years about how strong
we were how good we were how we've
delivered for the state those happen to
be true and now he's trying to backtrack
because he you know views he needs to do
that and he's saying things
okay so I know David has uh done deep
dives into kind of the way that the sand
just blows out of proportion how good
Florida has done and honestly a lot of
metrics but covid uh included and
Descendants the governance would be a
disaster Nationwide and all of that so
we'll set that aside but to the point of
oh Trump said all these good things
about me and now he's not can you
believe it yeah you lined up behind a
guy who understands nothing about actual
meaningful
um healthy loyalty and
um cares only about someone as far as
they can further his own goals so that's
very unsurprising but the Santas did the
same thing right DeSantis was doing that
campaign ad so cringy saying uh I don't
know exactly the specifics of the ad but
um you'll remember he's sitting with a
book reading to his child and uh make
America great again and essentially
indoctrinating his child into being a
trump supporter showing the supporters
in Florida I guess that I would be a
good candidate because
I love Trump so much and I'm teaching my
child to be like Trump and now he
doesn't have that same
um tone when talking about Trump of
course that's what happens constantly in
politics especially with people that
don't actually care about the people
they purport to
um unless they're they're helping
themselves politically but as far as
polling right now will DeSantis have to
make the decision as far as supporting
Trump or not supporting Trump in the
general election probably he will based
on polling
right now uh 538 has Trump at a 52.5
percent
average uh percentage point average
there and then santus is down at 21.3
percent and then everyone else way lower
so especially in past primary times
could DeSantis make up that difference
could a candidate at 21 end up jumping
up and beating someone who is at 52 sure
but because of how well known and how
um set in the feelings about these two
candidates and Trump in particular this
particular primary is and the followers
of these different individuals really
have a sense of especially who Trump is
the likelihood of a massive shift is uh
lesser it is not as likely that will
happen whereas other primaries there's a
lot of less known or a lot of candidates
that people aren't yet set in their
feelings about and so big shifts really
can happen especially this far out from
the actual election
um after debates and after lots of
campaigning and all of that but this is
a very different situation so likely
very soon distance will have to make a
decision about if he supports Trump in a
general and I can tell you almost 100
that he will support Trump if Trump's
the nominee against Biden that's just
how these things work unfortunately
whether you're a carpenter painter or
just want to be prepared for emergencies
if you need a gas mask or respirator go
to our sponsor parcel safety as many of
you know I'm into emergency preparedness
not crazy prepping but I want to have
some food stored some supplies I've
talked about water and multiple
respirators are part of that because
it's just a staple of being prepared
respirator sales have been way up in
recent years natural disasters wildfires
polluted air chemical plant accidents on
rest of different kinds militarized
police all sorts of different reasons
you never know when a respirator or a
gas mask from parcel safety might come
in handy and it could be when you least
expect it parcel safety respirators are
also perfect for professionals
contractors painters people doing DIY
projects at home all of parcel safety's
respirators come with a one-year
manufacturer's warranty every respirator
or gas mask comes with a filter
competitive prices large discounts for
organizations and outstanding customer
service to be totally honest I've said
before I'm using these for changing baby
diapers it's people think I'm kidding
and then they come visit me and I really
am not it it actually is very useful to
other parents out there I do recommend
it go to davidpackman.com safety use the
code Pacman for 25 off your first order
the link is down below